hablamos ahora de economía en france24 y
para eso saludamos a daniel hablando
nuestra periodista experta que nos va a
contar lo más importante hoy daniela en
brasil hay polémica por el cambio de la
presidencia de petrobras así es liliana
buenas noches pues hay vientos de crisis
en la empresa más grande de ese país es
controlada en un 50 26 por ciento por el
estado el presidente ya ir bolsonaro
despidió al ceo de petrobras roberto
castelo y nombró en su reemplazo a un
general retirado del ejército se trata
del ex ministro de defensa
joaquín silva el cambio se produce luego
de las críticas que recibió la empresa
por haber subido el precio de los
combustibles en cerca del 30 por ciento
en lo que va del año esta situación
estuvo a punto de llevar a huelga a los
camioneros que habían sido claves en la
elección de bolsonaro pues el mercado no
vio esta injerencia con buenos ojos y
castigó las acciones de la compañía en
alrededor del 20 por ciento en la
jornada de hoy
daniela ya eeuu se empezó a hablar del
dólar digital pues el auge que han
tenido las cripto monedas ha hecho que
los gobiernos del mundo empiecen a
pensar en monedas digitales supervisadas
y aunque en lugares como china y la
unión europea se ha venido discutiendo
bastante últimamente en eeuu si es una
novedad que se mencione la presidenta de
la reserva federal janet yellen criticó
este lunes al bitcoin pues lo considera
ineficiente por la gran cantidad de
energía que usa para procesar sus
transacciones en efecto a liliana un
estudio de la universidad de cambridge
dice que su consumo anual de energía
equivale a lo que demanda en países como
noruega argentina o ucrania después de
la crítica yellen reconoció la necesidad
de seguir explorando la posibilidad de
un dólar digital que estaría basado en
la misma tecnología que la script o
monedas pero supervisado esta vez por la
reserva federal veremos qué pasa ni la
la estadounidense boeing está en la mira
otra vez por un fallo en otro de sus
aviones después del sábado yo vieron
escombros de uno
los motores de un avión 777 sobre una
zona residencial deben ver en colorado
esto después de que la aeronave operada
por united airlines se incendiara
mientras volaba luego de despegar desde
entonces han llovido críticas por
supuestas fallas en la inspección por
parte de esta compañía que recordemos no
ha terminado de recuperar su reputación
tras dos accidentes mortales de su
modelo 737 max
los equipos de mantenimiento e
inspección aparentemente pasaron algo
por alto algunos defectos que se estaban
agravando con el tiempo esto no lo
sabemos todavía pero no parece que haya
sido causado por algún trauma de un
objeto que golpeó el motor parece ser
quizás un problema agravado por el uso
que debería haberse detectado en las
inspecciones liliana y después de este
incidente boeing que recomendó la
suspensión de los modelos que tuvieran
este mismo control de la marca pratt and
whitney pues en países bajos hubo otro
incidente con un motor de la misma marca
el reino unido- llave todo por ejemplo
la entrada de los boeing 777 a su
territorio hasta
no se aclare la situación daniela y
obligadas a botar cerveza las
cervecerías alemanas están pidiendo
ayuda si liliana a través de una carta
abierta al gobierno los representantes
de 300 cervecerías advirtieron que los
pubs los hoteles y los restaurantes han
recibido ayuda pero los productores no
en la misiva firmada por quienes
representan el 95 por ciento de la
cerveza que se elabora en alemania
aseguran que el cierre y el colapso del
mercado significó que las de cervecerías
perdieran una gran parte de sus bases
económicas de la noche a la mañana y
agregan que varios millones de euros en
cerveza que han superado su fecha de
caducidad pues han tenido que ser
desechados las cervecerías y los bares
están cerrados desde noviembre pasado en
el marco de la segunda ola de contagios
y todavía no se sabe cuándo van a volver
a abrir
daniela cuéntenos por ahora como a los
indicadores de la jornada sí señora
'wall street' del cerro mixto en un mal
día para las acciones tecnológicas del
nasdaq las bolsas europeas cayeron a
pesar de que se revelaron algunos datos
positivos
en alemania que es su principal economía
en américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
se desplomó en casi 5 % en medio de la
crisis institucional de petrobras y la
cifra del dia daniela 7,2 por ciento la
tasa de desempleo de paraguay en 2020
muy por encima del 57 de 2019 267 mil
personas sin trabajo en este país
daniela por la información de economía y
oeste gracias por estar en las 24
continúen con más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom
i